what's up guys oh sorry enough time I
didn't mean to interrupt you
oh what's up guys my lantern just went
out but luckily I have oil and welcome
to part 9 of let's play amnesia the Dark
Descent right as you know we left off
with me yet again kicking the ass of
many over what ha ha ha like I know be
around you didn't want to play whatever
whatever I'm gonna go that way
ah get back
I got a chair you wanna mess me I got a
chair ah Oh God ah ah I hit him I hit
him in the face with a charity [ __ ] yeah
I know that's a monster stop no don't
stop
I don't care there's a monster it's too
dangerous
changers in here I doubt that very much
Daniel you murdering bastard oh no not
another one oh my god oh my god aah oh
god it won't budge uh hide hide hide
hide hide hide hidey-hidey-ho Oh God
oh don't find me because I'm I'll throw
the box at him punch him in face and
then run like a little girl
go away he's gone yeah yeah yes that's
right Oh yep he's gone I'm the best
oh yeah that's right run away
best be hammer hammer
what what are you talking about it's a
hammer and chisel we will break that
thing off the wall as opposed to just
the padlock
Boozer because it didn't like me
throwing a chair at it oh whatever
shut up Daniel crazy everything I mean
it can't be do I deserve this yes it
wasn't my fault as it was I didn't have
to go in there don't go into burning
houses you should have known better
yeah whatever you murdered someone you
deserve all you got turned into a
monster didn't you that's what's going
you see yeah
oh yeah oh yeah this is my room
I know what's going on here yeah classic
murder-suicide by you except you're not
dead wait I guess the logic doesn't
follow but I'm still watching you well
wouldn't be a horror game without dead
naked guys I suppose stop using my torch
lantern so much for the boulders huh
18:39
the nightmares woke me in the early
morning and for a moment I forgot where
I was
are you Big B shortly after there was a
knock on my door Alexander had heard my
screams and asked me to join him in the
parlor ah isn't he as we drank her tea
Alexander began to tell me what he knew
it seems like the orb I found casts a
long and dark shadow uh-huh it's not
only a powerful item but a dangerous one
aha simply by touching it you invoke the
powers within and if you are too weak to
control it uh-huh it will devour you
weak like you - shadow is a sluggish
thing lagging behind the wielder killing
anyone or anything in its path to
reclaim the orb
so give it the orb I didn't care about
it's powers and I should throw it away
Alexander advised against this as I'd
still be a part of the path of the orb
and eventually suffered death having the
orb I would at least have the chance to
fight back when the time came yeah I
have a feeling I'm lying are you what he
meant when he said he could protect me
and he answered the things can be done
yeah but at a price
a murder a price bastard both Ian
bastards aah no aah
Oh don't hear the slamming door go away
yeah you ugly yes pray they only want me
because I'm so good-looking
DDD yeah you know
all right I have no idea what I'm doing
I'll go back to that
bucket ask you I don't know
don't judge me that's not right call it
C bread rebound shots in that needle
needle in there
ah aha
glass containers ideal where's a glass
container come on now be like that last
container glass container glassy glass
glass these other ones aha
come here give me some acid ah I had
acid but I had a I had a whole bucket of
acid before what did I use it all why
did I throw away the bucket
oh no I I blew up the bucket that's
right all right I'll keep going in
circles
jerks not you jerks viewing these jerks
in here jerks no storage all right
storage is their last we're in the
storage oh yeah this is why I ran away
in not in fear but in you know total
awesomeness oil
ah no glass container here looking
looking looking ah ha storage haha I'm
making progress progress
gimme-gimme-gimme right yeah that's
right ah yeah ah ha glass jar glass
container on my way to the kitchen
oh not again huh
go away go away I have AB I'm a chair
again you didn't like that last time
like it even less this time it's going
up your what whole chair up your butt
yes what I thought like : ah food up
kitchen ah Wow I got a chair back off
yeah yeah no one wants to mess with me
now
what surprise I got those signs are
posted I would get lost in here oh shut
up I got a chair back off yeah hey my
chair why did I do that
ah
no no no no no no acid fall in the acid
Oh God huh No
yeah yeah right yeah man these guys are
getting really getting after me but I'm
too tougher give me yo acid yeah
yeah that's right walk away I'll walk
away where are you going buddy
where are you going I want you to grab
my chair again but I don't even need a
chair it's so tough these guys don't
know right where am I there's something
over here
yeah ha blah blah what no why did I even
get it ah jerks
there's another one that was a weaker
version yeah besides what am I gonna use
on that a bomb I have a bomb had a bomb
I don't have it anymore no that way
nope I'm wrong I'm stupid most AHA oh
yeah
super smart here to the box yep Brewer
biggie blow up Lord and then smack ah
Oh where ah nope nope going ah ha I'm
the man cistern yeah oh yeah it ain't no
thing I got it
alright oh there's no dialog I'm gonna
pause it here again thanks so much for
watching I appreciate it and if you
enjoyed what you saw just be patient
part 10 is gonna come out real soon
thanks for watching